[Musik]
jetzt gewinnt an bedeutung weil sich
auch die bedrohungen verändern ich
möchte daran erinnern an die kritische
infrastruktur oder die kernaufgabe auch
ist der miliz diese zu schützen
durchaus ein realistisches szenario auch
wo die miliz auch unabdingbar ist aber
auch in vielen anderen bereichen
gespräche an den assistenzeinsatz an der
grenze oder auch den auslandseinsatz der
ohne miliz nicht dafür wie ein stift
martin ist mein name die ist gerade
vizeleutnant ich bin dies können da
eines jäger patheon seine minis
jägerbataillons und meine ziemlich
funktion
ich bin geschäftsführer im
luftfahrtbereich eines unternehmens ich
bin bei der miliz aus überzeugung weil
ich der meinung bin dass wir
staatsbürger auch dazu beitragen müssen
dass wir unsere staatsbürgerlichen
pflichten verteidigen können
[Musik]
weil es wichtig ist dass eine
verschränkung gibt das ist eine
win-win-situation die unternehmen
gewinnen deshalb weil ihre mitarbeiter
mit führungskompetenz auch mit
durchhaltevermögen zurück in den dienst
kehren und auch etwas lernen im system
bundesheer und umgekehrt gewinnt der
soldat weil ohne das unternehmen das
hier mitspielt auch gewisse dinge im
internet nicht möglich wären man muss
danke sagen an die unternehmen heute
auch schön des awards vergeben zu dürfen
ich hoffe es bleibt auch dabei und die
bewerbungen schnell herum